el 14 de agosto de 2021 un terremoto de
magnitud 7.2 dejó haití de rodillas más
de 2.200 muertos
137 mil hogares destruidos y 500 mil
afectados
los niños lloran porque necesitan comida
y agua estamos buscando por todas partes
pero sin conseguir nada
según la oficina de la onu para la
coordinación de asuntos humanitarios más
de 650 mil haitianos necesitan ayuda
humanitaria de emergencia del cual
apenas el 46 por ciento la recibió hasta
ahora y para llegar a todos los
damnificados la organización estima
necesitar más de 187 mil millones de
dólares pero hacer llegar los
suministros a los más necesitados no es
fácil la devastación del terremoto se
vio agravada por la depresión tropical
grave que provocó dos días después
inundaciones derrumbes dificultando aún
más el acceso a las zonas más remotas
especialmente en la provincia muy
afectada
camps aunque la comunidad humanitaria se
congratula de los esfuerzos de todas las
partes por llegar a las zonas más
afectadas este acceso tendrá que
mantenerse a largo plazo sobre todo si
se tienen en cuenta la falta de medios
aéreos y marítimos disponibles para
llegar a las personas afectadas tras las
sucesivas catástrofes que han sufrido
año tras año al dejar un efecto padre y
rápida las autoridades haitianas y sus
socios internacionales han prometido un
mejor manejo de la ayuda humanitaria
para evitar que se repita la historia de
2010 pero la unicef denuncia que más de
medio millón de niños carecen de refugio
y no tienen acceso a agua potable o
higiene abriendo la puerta a posibles
enfermedades como el cólera o la malaria
según esa misma organización más de 700
escuelas resultaron destruidas por el
terremoto una nueva calamidad que se
esfuma dos años en los que los niños se
han visto privados de escuela debido a
la inseguridad la inestabilidad política
y por supuesto la pandemia de cubi 19